eh bien monsieur bernadac je crois qu'il
faut que nous parlions des problèmes
économiques et sociaux bon si vous
voulez avant d'aborder votre politique
futur peut-être est-il nécessaire de
faire un retour en arrière car certains
français aussi bien des hommes
politiques que des simples citoyens vous
accuse et 10 votre gestion et
responsable des événements de mai et
donc de la crise que nous traversons
actuellement
bilan ces deux bilans qu'ils agissent si
je comprends bien
je voudrais dire à propos de bilan deux
ou trois choses tout d'abord on dit que
cette campagne électorale est égal et
que chaque concurrent a le même temps
mais moi je suis obligé de constater que
j'ai six concurrents qui attaquent
essentiellement ma personne et que je
suis un seul contre six mon dieu je vais
essayer de me défendre
ensuite je voudrais limiter le problème
du bilan
je ne discute ni le critique que ce qu'a
fait la cinquième république avant moi
ou ce qu'elle a fait après c'est moi qui
suis candidat donc je parle bilan pour
la période 1962 68 où j'ai été premier
ministre et à ce propos d'ailleurs je
dois dire que je m'étonne je m'étonne de
m'entendre critiqué par des hommes qui
ont été au pouvoir pendant la quatrième
république monsieur de fer où monsieur
mendès-france et qui devrait bien aussi
faire leur propre bilan j'ai discuté à
grenoble on s'en souvient peut-être
devant un public presque entièrement
main désiste de bilan de la quatrième et
de mon bilan respectifs et je n'ai pas
eu l'impression d'avoir le dessous à
l'époque et quant à monsieur poher je
dois dire que depuis dix ans il n'a
jamais critiqué cette politique
économique et sociale afin
parlons bilan donc et vous dit que je
serai responsable des événements de mai
mais les événements de mai ils ont eu
lieu partout cette révolte universitaire
a été générale c'est vrai qu'en france
ça a pris des proportions un peu plus
étendus c'était plus long mais peut-être
si j'avais fait comme ailleurs donné
latran si j'avais pas hésité à tuer
certaines nombre d'étudiants ça serait
arrêté plus tôt mais ça je ne le voulait
pas et je crois que les français ne ment
pas donner tort
on joue en général du candidat parfois
sur sa mine mais toujours et avant tout
sur son programme alors si vous le
voulez bien monsieur nous allons
maintenant parler d'eux de votre
programme non je suis disposé à revenir
sur le problème du bilan parce qu'enfin
il faut le faire sur le plan économique
et sur le plan social
et puis nous parlerons de la suite
bilan économique
à quoi est-ce qu'on mesure un bilan à
les chiffres je voudrais pas écraser les
spectateurs sous les chiffres j'en
donnerai tout de même quelques-uns
1,62 quand j'arrive au pouvoir les
autoroutes ont samples c'est vrai il y
en avait 77 km en 6 ans j'en ai mis en
service 900 est en chantier plus de
mille le téléphone dieu sait si l'on
s'en plaint aussi c'est vrai
2950 2 à 58 pour prendre une période de
même durée on a mis en service sept cent
mille nouveaux abonnés j'en ai mis en
service deux millions 900 mille
les hôpitaux
le 1962 à 1968 on a construit plus
d'hôpitaux qu entre 1900 et 1970
budget de l'éducation nationale je les
fais passer de 9% à plus de 17 % du
budget budget des armées je les ramener
de près de 30 % à un peu plus de 17%
il faut finir par un chiffre global eh
bien il existe un organisme qui
s'appelle l'oscd et qui regroupe tous
les pays industrialisés à l'exception
des pays communistes de 1962 à 1968 pour
la croissance du produit national en
volume par valeur parce qu'en valeur on
pourrait me parler de la hausse des prix
en volume la france arrive au second
rang après le japon qui ne l'est pas
c'est vrai de loin et devant tous les
autres notamment devant l'allemagne
croyez vous que ce soit si mal bien sûr
je ne prétends pas que ce soit idéal
loin de là mais enfin je peux dire que
j'ai fait mieux que ceux qui m'attaquent
c'est déjà quelque chose et quant au
bilan social vous savez pour moi c'est
avant tout un problème de niveau de vie
et bien de 1962 à 1968 le nombre des
voitures
un foyer sur trois quand je suis arrivé
un sur deux est même plus d'un sur deux
quand je suis parti avait une voiture
et frigidaire
ils ont doublé pendant ces 6 m
les télévisions ont triplé
le pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages
s'est accrue en tenant compte du prix de
la vie vous me comprenez bien s'est
accru de 27 % celui des salariés un peu
plus solide agriculteurs un peu moins ça
fait en moyenne près de 4 %
d'augmentation par an ce qui non plus
n'est pas si mal et quant au prix de la
vie c'est vrai il a augmenté la augmenté
en moyenne de 3,1 8% par an c'est trop
mais vous savez combien c'était pendant
la quatrième république
11% par an alors qu'il fasse un peu leur
bilan et nous parlerons du mit ensuite
voulez vous ça c'était le le passé
l'avenir qu'elle est sur votre programme
oui c'est vrai il faut parler pour moi
je n'aime pas le mot programme vous le
savez il n'est pas gaulliste car c'est
un tissu de promesses contient ou
contient pas je parle d'objectif c'est à
dire les choses que je veux essayer
d'atteindre que tous mes efforts qui
évidemment je ne suis pas absolument sûr
d'atteindre surtout si personne ne
m'aide bon allongé face le le mot
programme vos objectifs
mais objet eh bien nous sommes en
économie il ya trois domaines essentiels
l'industrie le commerce l'agriculture
l'industrie d'abord
c'est du point de vue purement
économique
probablement ce qui est le plus
important
le monde moderne est un monde industriel
il faut donc faire de la france un grand
pays moderne c'est-à-dire grands pays
industrie
pour cela que peut faire l'état
eh bien l'état doit favoriser
l'investissement
il ne s'agit pas d'enrichir les patrons
ou les actionnaires il s'agit de
permettre aux entreprises d'investir de
façon à se moderniser et en se
modernisant de produire davantage à
meilleur compte pour vendre meilleur
marché et vendre davantage à l'étrange
là doit être l'effort de l'état le plan
doit permettre de donner les grandes
lignes de l'avenir industriel
il faut aider puissamment
l'initiative il faut la laisser se
dégager se libérer des entraves de la
technocratie c'est ce que j'ai déjà dit
à plusieurs reprises donc efforts
industriels importants efforts également
régional pour que cette industrie
s'installe partout et non pas dans deux
ou trois régions efforts pour que cette
industrie soit favorisée par l'état et
non pas qu'on traque voilà pour
l'industrie
qui a besoin
d'incitations d'excitation de facilité
pour tout dire de libération
le commerce
le commerce évolue lui aussi
le grand commerce prend une place de
plus en plus importante reconnaissons le
et c'est une évolution nécessaire que
personne n'empêchera
mais dans cette évolution
il faut ménager
ce qui existe je pense aux petits
commerces je pense aussi à quelque chose
de voisins qui et l'artisanat
non pas du tout par souci de
conservatisme
mais parce que je crois profondément
que le petit commerce et l'artisanat
sont nécessaires à l'équilibré social
d'un pays et qu'en même temps il apporte
à la vie de tout le monde une sorte de
caractère plus humain - mécanique et qui
est indispensable donc laisser
progresser le grand commerce mais en le
contrôlant dans sa croissance
aider le petit commerce l'artisanat en
les libérant des servitudes
administrative de contrôle tatillon de
charges fiscales excessives pour leur
permet de se moderniser eux aussi de se
mettre au goût du jour
d'accompagner l'évolution au lieu d'en
être écrasé voilà en gros mon programme
j'ai défini plus en détails lorsque j'ai
rencontré des représentants de la
profession ou des parlementaires qui
était leur porte-parole mais cela vous
savez je ne le dis pas des fins
électorales j'ai dit quand j'étais
premier ministre j'ai commencé par un
certain nombre de mesures et je continue
à le dire au passage d'ailleurs je
signale que l'avons pris loi sur
l'assurance maladie qui fait beaucoup
couler d'encre et de salive et qui avait
été élaboré pourtant en plein accord
avec les professions elle se révèle
imparfaite il faut la réviser
vous avez oublié je pense les
agriculteurs les agriculteurs disent
toujours on nous oublie eh bien écoutez
figurez-vous g s'est gardé pour la fin
j'ai gardé pour la fin parce que si
quelqu'un ne peut pas les oublier c'est
bien moi petit fils de paysan et qui
encore beaucoup de cousins qui
travaillent la terre et je vous assure
une terre qui n'est pas riche
alors en matière agricole
j'ai deux
idées principales
il y à une agriculture moderne
industrielle dans ses méthodes dans les
grandes plaines du bassin paris c'est
elle qui va fournir lamaze céréales de
betteraves sucrières et autres avec
lesquels nous devons pouvoir fournir nos
partenaires du marché comme
et puis
il y a une petite agriculture familiale
celle ci souffre encore de certains et
superficies sont trop étroites les
charges départ pour les jeunes sont trop
lourdes l'équipement et en particulier
le confort des foyers est encore dans
bien des régions insuffisant et je les
connais ces régions que ce soit la
bretagne que ce soit le maine où la
normandie que ce soit l'eau vers le
rouergue le quercy je pourrais vous en
énumérer pas mal où j'ai passé beaucoup
il faut donc remembrer cette agriculture
familiale telle sorte que nous ayons des
exploitations plus importante et mieux
organisés et qu'ils soient rentables
mais il faut sauver l'agriculture
familiale
parce que c'est à la fois une nécessité
sociale est une société
pour la france même que je ne veux pas
transformer en de grandes villes d'un
côté et une sorte de désert par ailleurs
cela veut dire que nous devons à
l'intérieur du marché comme un être
extrêmement énergique avec nos
partenaires et en particulier
repoussé telle ou telle partie du plan
mansholt qui serait absolument
dramatique pour cet agriculteur
j'ai souvent entendu dire autour de moi
et là il nous faut revenir une dernière
fois je pense en arrière georges
pompidou a été pendant un certain temps
animateur d'une célèbre banque
d'affaires
il est l'homme du grand capital comment
voulez vous que cet homme est une
politique sociale et bien écoutez
je m'en suis expliqué ce matin même très
clairement à la radio sur france inter
et j'espère qu'on l'aura entendu
j'ai peut-être était-ce dans la banque
en effet pendant quelques années mais je
suis fils d'instituteur j'étais
universitaire j'ai été fonctionnaire au
conseil d'état j'étais au gouvernement
et en fin de compte en choisissant de
suivre le général de gaulle eh bien j'ai
renoncé à la fortune je ne suis pas sûr
que tout le monde puisse en dire autant
mais mon programme social il existe
aussi croyez le bien ou mes objectifs
souci
seulement je voudrais d'abord dire
quand on parle social on croit toujours
qu'il s'agit des rapports entre les
ouvriers et les patrons de l'industrie
7 est vrai au 19e siècle où c'était le
grand problème la culture le commerce
les professions diverses vivait comme
toujours et l'industrie se transformait
et elle se transforme et aux dépens des
ouvriers 12 grands mouvements
socialistes qu'ils soient germanique
avec karl marx qu'ils soient plus humain
plus sentimental comme le socialisme
français qui a abouti à jean jaurès
aujourd'hui il ya bien d'autres choses
du point de vue social
il y à des catégories défavorisées
si tu es tout à l'heure les petits
agriculteurs
je citais tout à l'heure aussi les
petits commerçants et petits artisans je
pourrais même site et les cadres moyens
qui lorsqu'ils sont un peu âgés s'y
perdent leur emploi ont beaucoup de mal
à se reclasser
je pense surtout aux personnes âgées
quand j'étais au gouvernement la vème
république a plus que doublé
leurs allocations elle reste néanmoins
insuffisante est inférieur à ce qu'il y
a chez nos voisins allemands par exemple
voilà un effort priorité
je pense à tant d'enfants handicapés
autrefois
on laisser mourir et qui aujourd'hui
vivent grâce au ciel mais qu'il faut
aider eux et leur famille à vivre à
pouvoir trouver une occupation une vie
aussi normale que possible
là aussi c'est un grand effort et qui me
touche
particulière
voilà quelques-unes des catégories
ciblées nom auquel je pense
particulièrement prioritaire alors
revenons à la classe ouvrière alors j'en
viens à la classe ouvrière parce
qu'évidemment c'est le grand problème
que l'on pose et que l'on m'oppose
et bien sûr la condition des ouvriers
mon idée là dessus la première chose
c'est le niveau de vie
c'est-à-dire le salaire et les
conditions de vie c'est à dire le
logement
l'équipement ménager qui est soulagement
de la femme de l'ouvrier la société de
consommation la société de consommation
je ne crois pas qu'il faille la détester
quand il s'agit de donner à la femme
d'un ouvrier où la femme la paysans un
frigidaire une machine à laver ou une
cuisinière électrique
je crois même cet excellent
et puis ya
l'environnement
le les transports par exemple si
fatigante pour les ouvriers salariés de
la région parisienne il faut ça l'occupé
russe et puis il ya l'organisation du
travail dans l'usiné il ya les rapports
entre les ouvriers et les patrons alors
là nous avons fait des choses
j'ai fait voter une loi de participation
aux bénéfices au je sais bien que on ne
s'en aperçoit pas beaucoup parce qu'elle
commençait sur l'année 68 etc l'année 68
produit des bénéfices risquent d'être
médiocre à cause des grèves mais elle
existe il ya les comités d'entreprise
dont j'ai fait augmenter les pouvoirs il
ya la loi permettant l'action syndicale
que j'ai promise à grenelle et que le
gouvernement ne se couvrent de murville
a fait voter et il ya surtout les
rapports sociaux à l'intérieur de cette
entreprise
et j'estime d'abord que
les ouvriers les cadres les employés
doivent être au courant doivent être
informés de ce que fait l'entreprise de
ce que ses dirigeants se propose de
faire de leurs objectifs de leurs
résultats de leurs difficultés c'est ce
devoir d'information que l'étape leur
imposer c'est d'ailleurs de ça comme par
le général de gaulle quand ils me
parlaient de participation
pour le reste eh bien il faut pousser à
une plus grande collaboration
à ce que les ouvriers les salariés ne
soient pas des robots à ce qu'il soit
intéressé à leur travail directement
mais ça est à petit un site et il pleut
favorisés mais ça dépend avant tout des
conventions entre les syndicats et le
patronat
ça dépend avant tout des rapports
humains entre les patrons et les
ouvriers on peut faire une bonne loi sur
le mariage ça n'a jamais fait que le
mari et la femme s'aiment et s'entendent
et bien une bonne loi sur les
entreprises ne le fera pas non plus il
faut des conventions direct discuter
entre syndicats et patronat et
d'ailleurs c'est l'avis des syndicats et
c'est l'avis du patronat en outre 67 je
me souviens j'écris au patronat en
lisant je voudrais vous parler avec les
syndicats des problèmes d'emploi et de
chômage
eh bien il a fallu 18 mois pour que ça
se fasse mais ça c'est fait et ça donne
satisfaction à tout le monde oui il faut
transformer la condition ouvrière mais
ça n'est pas l'état seul qui peut le
faire il faut que les ouvriers syndicats
le veuille et il faut surtout que les
patrons le veuille et deviennent plus
moderne plus humain plus compréhensif
comme l'est d'ailleurs un patron
véritable au xxème siècle aux états unis
par exemple c'est le cas nous n'avons
pas pardonné monsieur du du franc j'ai
souvent entendu dire également avec le
départ du général de gaulle est tombé le
dernier rempart qui nous protégeait
d'une dévaluation notre monnaie malade
peut être perdu
jouer basse or qui dit ça j'ai connu les
situations au pire car monsieur guy
mollet par exemple est arrivé au pouvoir
monsieur de fer était un des principaux
de ces mini il y avait dans les caisses
si je me souviens bien
400 millions de dollars c'était très peu
quand il est parti j'en avais 0 jeudi 0
$ bon rouleur actuel qu'est ce que nous
avons peut-être 3 milliards de dollars
ou 4 je ne sais pas exactement alors
nous pouvons encore nous défendre ceci
étant dit c'est vrai notre monnaie peut
être en péril elle peut être en péril si
notre économie ne progresse pas si la
france se met pas au travail si nous
n'avons pas une expansion rapide ce qui
est mon objet mon but est aussi si la
confiance ne règne pas si les hommes
n'expire pas confiance s'il n'y a pas la
stabilité gouvernementale qui seul donne
la sécurité et créer la confiance mais
précisément c'est vers cela que je tends
croyez-le bien
je ne crois pas du tout que la monnaie
soit perdu il faut la défendre
mais la monnaie ce comme l'expansion
c'est comme le niveau de vie c'est
finalement comme le bonheur des hommes
ça dépend de la tranquillité de la
sécurité et la sécurité
françaises français
vous le savez bien elle ne vient que de
la stabilité politique
et cette stabilité politique vous le
laver qu'à condition qu'il y ait un
gouvernement rénové efficaces s'appuyant
une majorité très large et répondant à
l'impulsion aux directives d'un chef
d'état qui est l'autorité et qui soit
capable de rassurer parce qu'on sait là
les circonstances difficiles il est
capable de fermeté avoue françaises et
français de savoir